[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va voir de quelle
est la conduite à tenir face à une
personne qui saigne abondamment tu veux
appuyer sur ta plait ou pas rose non tu
veux pas bon écoute je vais appuyer à ta
place voilà elle peut pas appuyer parce
que ça lui fait peur c'est donc moi qui
vais appuyer et qui vais allonger la
victime au sol
pour permettre au sang d'irriller toutes
les parties nobles et donc préserver la
conscience donc je vais appeler ce cours
avec le téléphone en précisant qu'elle a
une hémorragie mais si maintenant j'ai
besoin de me libérer
pour pouvoir effectivement appeler ce
cours et bien je vais
remplacer ma main par ma ceinture une
écharpe tiens justement elle a une
écharpe autour du cou ça tombe bien avec
ce lien large je vais remplacer l'appui
je fais avec ma main sur le tampon qui
accentue la pression sur sa main donc
effectivement je vais
positionner le lien large et entourer
tout le pansement
pour comprimer le lien large à la place
de ma main voilà en veillant
effectivement que toute la pièce soit
recouverte
je vais faire un nœud
je rassure la victime t'inquiète pas tu
vois regarde ça ne saigne plus tu ne
restes plus rien et avant justement de
me libérer pour alerter les secours je
vais veiller effectivement à couvrir la
victime pour la préserver
préserver la chaleur de son corps les il
faut absolument tenir au chaud les
victimes d'hémorragiques
pour éviter l'hypothermie surveiller
effectivement que le pansement est
efficace